mais est ce qu'ils vont chercher à aimer
je vous ai déjà vu que vous êtes le mec
qui joue rassurez-vous tout ceci du
cinéma commente un acteur au bout de mon
nez ou est ce qu'ils vont chercher tout
ça
voici dans les locaux du studio bac 2
golden moustache golden moustache est
avant tout des sketches et quel meilleur
endroit pour commencer la visite en
scène la salle des auteurs voilà ce
moment-là il referme sa main et les
crasses s'est très vite à vis la salle
du directeur la salle technique la salle
des tigres mauvais investissements on a
très peu de sketches avec les tigres
nous voici à présent dans la salle des
effets spéciaux c'est ici que le
merveilleux prend vie comme par exemple
un petit mot tout petit moineau dans ma
main holden moustache c'est avant tout
un site internet
alors vous allez me dire qu'est ce qu'il
a de spécial ce site internet google
donne moustache points comme vous pouvez
voir les sketchs 24 heures avant leur
sortie sur youtube et si vous souscrivez
aux comptes premium rétroactif vip plus
vous pouvez voir les sketchs avant même
qu'il soit tourné par contre il faut
imaginer que la évidemment il ya des
pouvoirs parce que c'est de post
production
je m'envole enfin il sera avec du sud 1
c'est également sur le site que vous
trouverez en exclusivité les vidéos du
lab
ici on expérimente on teste de nouvelles
idées les nouvelles blagues sont une
et du coup la vidéo ça serait une
parodie de game of thrones
mais avec de la mie de pain tu peux me
rappeler ton prénom
s'il te plaît yannick bacaria nique les
golden moustache est avant tout du
contenu original des articles des
montages hilarant des making-of
d'ailleurs en ce moment même nous sommes
en train de tourner le making of de
cette vidéo mais nous tournoi également
le making-of des making-of des making of
taking off du making-of arrêté dans ces
[ __ ] en plus du contenu exclusif vous
trouverez le meilleur d'internet
sélectionné par notre prospecteurs
d'humour digital l'irremplaçable pierre
trapu merci dimitri nous avec les
copains on a mis une caméra on april
music et 5e l'entourent salut club
oui nous y allons pour un champ en quoi
non mais c'est bon je vais le prendre
golden moustache points comme c'est
enfin et avant tout une plateforme
participative où chacun et chacune peut
proposer du contenu comme par exemple
des montages avec du groupe up step de
bâtard
bienvenue dans cette troisième saison
avec un nouveau site et des tigres